benvenuti solido da
oggi ha grandissimi fama ripresa perché
fate chiesto in tanti giocheremo a pochi
il play time che si chiama anche a
chiunque gates è un nuovo gioco molto
pauroso e
98 se non vi piacciono le cose paurose
vi lascio qua adesso una finestrella ho
qua ho qua che si aprirà per vedere i
nostri altri video divertenti e noi
paurose andate a vederli qua mi
piacciono le cose favolose sapere che
noi adoriamo le cose paurose questo
gioco dovrebbe essere molto pauroso e
non vedo l'ora di vedere come sarà più
pauroso dia iscrivo o meno pauroso di
ice cream scrivetecelo poi voi alla fine
nei commenti se secondo voi più paolo su
questo o ice scream siete pronti prende
tipo chorme lasciate un mi piace
questo è il video di introduzione
ha detto ho
detto visto per presentare la bambola
più
intelligenti
[Musica]
mischia un po ti voglio bene
quindi stiamo vorremmo una vecchia
pubblicità d pasticcio quello che si
chiama probabili la bambola
[Musica]
sono una bambina reale ha detto
che nessuno migliore di giocare
questa invece la fabbrica delle
bombolette può visitare si può visitare
la fabbrica delle bombe
[Musica]
che succede è successo qualcosa alla
fabbrica delle bambole
c'è scritto tutti quanti pensano che il
personale sia sparito dieci anni fa ma
siamo ancora qua trova il fiore e ci ha
disegnato un fiore eccoci qua allora che
cosa hanno detto nel video iniziale mi
raccomando studiate l'inglese ragazzi
studiate linguaggio per vico di capire
del tutto nel video giochi manca per
rendere la serie tv potrete guardare
lingua originale tantissime altre cose è
utilissimo quelle studiate l'inglese
cosa hanno detto in pratica era un video
vecchio di una pubblicità di una bambola
che si chiama a poppi è un signore
diceva abbiamo creato una bambola che
non è mai esistita ma è stata creata
prima d'ora c'è una bambola che riesce a
capirti ad ascoltarti a rispondere e si
chiama poppi in inglese poppy anche il
fiore del papavero
quindi che cosa succede adesso poi c'era
scritto che c'era un biglietto in cui
dieci anni fa sono scomparsi gli
impiegati in questa fabbrica cose la
fabbrica che ha creato la bambola poppi
e ha creato varie altre bambole quindi
non sappiamo che cosa è successo
questa ambientazione mi ricorda un po
ben di errani di servizi sono i rumori
strani questo gioco si saranno anche
vari jobs che
sapete idem scherzano quando
all'improvviso spunta fuori qualcosa c'è
un rumore fortissimo quindi ti spaventi
a baseball internet
le scatole vuote stiamo esplorando la
fabbrica di giocattoli ma è fittissimo e
così sono tutti i giocattoli che stavano
costruendo è tutto distrutto tipo e
abbandonato guarda sopra
c'è un trenino che dopo dieci anni
continua ancora
sembra una bomba
ecco io mi sono spaventato anche se non
è successo niente ok allora bisogna
trovare il codice con questi colori
probabilmente no
cerchi un questo come dove li possiamo
trovare queste economie terra si sono
dei colori nel giallo blu e rosso
territori delle mattonelle
credo che manchi ancora un colore vasta
cassetto
è una cassetta ma qui
che
ha detto che era poco partirà l'allarme
perché ci siamo introdotti nella
fabbrica testa perfetto e quindi ha
detto questo il tuo avviso di comi
ritornare indietro andare via ma forse
sono questi colori per aprire quello del
trenino verde rosa già nostro verde rosa
giallo e rosso dobbiamo era verder de
rosa rosa giallo giallo rosso
sembra molto un'altra cassanata city ma
cosa ci diranno ora
in time e tipo un giocattolo sono tipo
delle mani allungabili
permira per difendersi una volta che
troviamo il pupazzo malefico dove sarei
un aspetto sia questo ma che il sistema
fantastico
che
sappiamo che ti dico per allontanare il
pupazzo
vicino a 16 anni l'altra mano dove
effettivamente ce l'abbiamo solo una per
ora entriamo qui vediamo che cover di
esplorare tutte super interessante
esplorare la fabbrica di giocattoli
abbandonato c'è una mano la sopra
proviamo
sì
eccolo lì non si muove
credo dobbiamo fare
inseguirà aiuto
come gigante qui è davvero solo un
giocattolo non si muove no
spero alla fine ha una faccia sorridente
fatica allora che ci sono anche i suoi
panni non sono stato io quindi il
pupazzo si chiama
casiraghi ei pupa vedi qui c'è due mani
dobbiamo trovare l'altra mano allora
attento non svegliarlo infatti si svegli
uccise
e ha fatto le scintille verso power che
però ho sentito il rumore di chiave
ecco c'è una chiamata sopra
cos'era non si è mosso per fortuna si è
acceso qui lo stesso lo pupazzo non si
muoverà
se abbiamo fatto aperta la porta
è ancora lì
c'è una keyword di rosa
[Musica]
vediamoci
intorno c'è una camera di sicurezza puoi
devi essere gentile con gli altri che
poi arrivare il quale è
non nasconderti dietro alle porte come
da non fare non puoi stare qua dopo le
otto di sera
no noi non ci staremo dopo le otto di
sera non puoi toccare i macchinari e non
puoi entrare nel settore innovazione
dell'organizzazione settore in quello
che abbiamo visto prima quello incontri
ha incontratro specie di esperimenti
importante che oggi walking non si
svegli per il resto possiamo esplorare
quanto vogliamo
o no sei sicura che è una buona idea
io posso spostare la corrente bresson
elettronico ha detto wow
ma che sto facendo e dove puoi portarla
bow wow nostra è una cosa fantastica
dovrebbe capito come funziona però forse
dobbiamo portare la corrente quanti sono
i casi
abbiamo acceso la cosa che ho fatto
adesso funziona continuiamo la nostra
esplorazione
non c'è più è scomparso non c'è più ma
di onenote e preoccupato
dove sarà andato non lo voglio sapere
non potete sapere dov'è andato il
problema se riusciamo andare qui
caffetteria forse come abbiamo attivato
l'elettricità lui funziona con
l'elettricità e quindi si è attivato
anche lui
perché non sono dentro ha funzionato una
nuova aria c'è scritto vai amicizia
candy che questo era un altro gioco che
sicuramente hanno creato nella fabbrica
stai molto attento
è troppo
bello c'è scritto né
salerno e quindi dobbiamo per forza
entrare qua in cui c'è scritto da votare
ma non possiamo magari andare bene
e cominciano già ad averlo tutto il tour
è alta
apriamo
e tipo un magazzino
di questa musichetta questo si può
aprire no qui c'è un registratore c'è
un'altra cassetta e dover rincorrere
un'altra cassetta cerchi ancora
non la vedo
a qui c'era il giochino quello che
abbiamo visto l'annata sicuramente c'è
piste rosse qualche pericolo no cos'è
questo
dove siamo
questa fabbrica è molto strana possibile
degli esperimenti strani qua che così
presa ho preso un qualcosa che era
fianchi qui si può aprire
ai uso forse l'ho dentro
a nos qui è dove stavamo prima
ok
facciamo un giro vediamo se troviamo
qualcosa
questo è un altro gioco qui c'è qualcosa
piccola
forse dobbiamo prendere tutti i colori
di questi suoli a ecco la cassetta e
andiamo a vederla passa da qua sotto
diretto guarda c'è un altro vediamo che
cosa c'è anche intorno
e c'è un'altra mano rossa guarda c'è una
bambola li chiama mezzo di bambola
quando nella fabbrica stavano costruendo
con le bambole quindi qui dobbiamo
mettere ragazza ti vediamo che inizia
che c'erano due impiegati che litigavano
1 ha detto dove hanno messo le scatole
di adua chi non trovava le scatole
l'altro gli ha detto non sono stato là e
poi hanno iniziato a litigare perché
dicevano che non funzionano bene le cose
in questa fabbrica insomma non erano
molto contenti quindi chissà che cosa è
successo poi
bravo sì abbiamo ancora uno mi sa
vediamo guarda lo stesso sulla mano
rossa
che se fosse vero però dobbiamo trovare
un modo per prenderla così poi avremo
tutti e due le mani possiamo prevedere a
premere i pulsanti o no erano i pezzi di
giocattolo che volava saltavo
esattamente prendere anche la mano rotta
come possiamo fare a salire da sopra
prima dobbiamo trovare il sesto rozzo
secondo me poi si sbloccherà forse vero
che succede abbiamo messo tutti segnerà
tori si sta aprendo qualcosa lì
mi sono rotta giusta portando qui
è la buttata giù
giusto niente da rubare non eravamo lì
sotto nino aquila voto lavori non
prendere quei due pulsanti lì quindi
dovrei prendere prima con la mano blu e
poi la mano rossa
c'è scritto non entrare
pienamente entreremo lo stesso
aspetta barbero dio che paura 48
mentre dobbiamo andare
siamo tipo nel ruolo un portatore di
giochi ok
preferiamo da qui no qui ci fa scelte
scivolare buffa e poi possiamo andare al
secondo quesito
ok qua c'è una contro il circo uniti è
però aspetta se non possiamo passare a
ok forse dobbiamo dare da qui e da te
l'altro forse qui sopra si e aspetto
momento ma ogni volta che attiviamo
l'elettricità si muove a chi guardi mi
sembra perché l'altra volta abbiamo
attivato l'elettricità rialzo di wight e
scomparso da dov'era quindi non è che se
magari attiviamo tutta l'elettricità
eccolo si
attiviamo la mano a mossi
avremmo approvato
adesso qualsiasi cosa salta casa
attivata a destra ok abbiamo capito come
voterà finalmente dobbiamo rendere la
corrente action brand spalla
e portarla al
numero 22 e dovrebbe azionarsi adesso
ok ha funzionato girati dove stiamo
andando nessun altro ma ha affermato
questa sorta di tapis roulant un altro
nullo stiamo vedendo dove si è votato
non mi dire che c'era questa girato
sempre guardato avanti
[Musica]
da ros stanno cadendo dei giocattoli
aiuto
forse dobbiamo correre
[Musica]
dove stiamo finendo
siamo bus era tutto ok ma un bambino può
essere il rullo dove trasportavano i
pezzi di giocattoli ha quindi qua siamo
in mano a farò né un'altra area della
fabbrica proprio dove componevano i
giocattoli c'è scritto che anche qua ci
serve l'elettricità
vediamo come qua sopra
ho trovato un altro video registratore
che rosa bene dobbiamo trovare la
cassetta e così scopriamo più indizi su
quello che è successo in questa fabbrica
e sono cassetta guarda
penso si bravo
che allora nella cassetta diceva è bello
perché è deciso di lavorare fabbriche ha
detto beh perché
incastrato la mano
e lì ha detto perché io adoro i
giocatori quando ero piccolo giocavo lì
giocato lì potevo andare in qualsiasi
modo volessi giocando quindi mi piace
lavorare qua perché posso creare i
giocattoli per i bambini che possono
giocare andare i rimondi che vogliono
qui ci sono altre due stazioni da da per
l'elettricità quindi dovremo attivare
queste troviamo
o no non arriva fino a lì come mai ha
funzionato a uno lo abbiamo acceso anche
l'altro che adesso che abbiamo capito
come fare
se anche voi avete fermato questo gioco
sicuramente sarà stato un po difficile
sui vestiti come ttp riusciti o è stato
un po difficile da capire allora bisogna
prima attirare quel carrellino qua poi
attivi ha dunque da forse ci siamo
l'abbiamo fatto e quindi questo è il
percorso da fare lo vedete quindi e dai
buoni così e puoi attaccare la quasi
relatore numero diamo sanziona
supporto a posto sarà difficilissima
questa parte abbiamo attivato questa
parte ad ora che abbiamo finalmente
attivato l'elettricità dover difficile
adesso possiamo attivare la fabbrica
potrebbe funzionare adesso abbiamo messo
l'elettricità acqui asti perché diceva
attiva l'elettricità e orazioni britos
queste macchine sono la forma di mostro
o non si erano perse video caso del
mattino
[Musica]
e quest'anno scende il vestito che io
devo proprio riattivato la fabbrica wow
è anche questa
e adesso adesso si comporranno i
giocattoli forse usciranno da qui chi è
vivo
dobbiamo prendere un giocattolo finito
proviamo uscire da claudio fatica
aiuto
co sta succedendo qualcosa guarda sto
facendo giocattolo premio prima che
affidiamo che giocattolo abbiamo
costruito con queste fabbriche ecco
tutto arrivando non c'era un mostro non
farà spunta fuori anche qua chi così
all'improvviso ecco lo facciamo un
gattino era quello di cui abbiamo visto
il poco prima ok ora che abbiamo questo
qualcosa qua
questo che cos'è
no nessuno può andarsene senza un
giocattolo ok forse bisogna metterlo qua
per il controllo qualità o che cameri
l'acqua
già aperto la porta
e maghi orchi femmina
quando si andrà arese scritto
qua non si può andare
[Applauso]
schiuma casco cosa questa che cosa ci
faceva la ben 38 perché proprio di no
c'è chiuso
coppa papà non è il tuo momento
alzati ancora vivi siamo ok siamo
tornati dov'eravamo primo ma ci sarà
ancora chi vuol dire ha dentro acuiti
dobbiamo andare di qua
facciamo
che brutta
fondersi dove dobbiamo andare non lo so
proprio gigante del genio assoluto
riproviamo questa forza proveremo a
scappare molto velocemente siete troppi
lasciate mi piace se questo video
raggiunge i 20 mila mica se giocheremo a
chi web di scopi playtime nella vita
reale quindi lo so che non mi piace qua
sotto che ancora non è uscita perché non
esce più per chi vuole che ti amo
detiene il più basso di non rischio
scappare
io dirmi
viveva a tornare nel ruolo
di tosca
fortunato
non sono ad andare
no lui ci senza guardano lui e dietro di
noi che ci stiamo però saltata
forse riusciremo a scappare poter
riuscire a scappare
ok riproviamo penso che sarà molto
difficile ma siamo vicini alla fine
possiamo farcela dove sta andando non
uso a destra troppo potevi andare a
testa che non hanno sbagliato abbiamo
preso il panis tapis roulant che porta
indietro pro forse così anche a chi vuol
chi non riesce a raggiungere i cieli
forse questa è una tecnica continua a
sorprendere batteri che
si porterà direttamente a lui ok allora
abbiamo preso la strada sbagliata
credo dove sarà finito strano che a chi
non non c'è
sempre riusciti a seminarlo forza magari
lui e da qualche altra parte
sì siamo riusciti a seminare una belice
continare no no
spero che sia la strada giusta
o non si è chiusa la porta qui vai vai
o no ma verso infatti si 6 guardi corri
e quello che sto facendo
ok adesso c'è una scatola sopra inutile
in testa
noi non ce l'abbiamo fatta
ritirato la scatola e lui è caduto giù
guardava spetta al governo lo vedo è
caduto giù hai fatto cadere giù attento
non cadere giù ma io sono un abisso
abbiamo 500 milioni l'offerta
migliore ma abbiamo trovato perché
dovevamo trovare dall'inizio allora
adesso dove dobbiamo andare in credo che
abbiamo fatto credere che i guai che
abbiamo eliminato per sempre spero che
non tornerà ad allora poi c'è un
labirinto siamo verso il fiore spero che
ora riusciremo a scappare una volta per
tutte da questa fabbri qui c'è una
cassetta
forse questa è l'ultima cassetta
guerra ci sono tanti giocatori attesi
c'è scritto vai via torna indietro
adesso penso che dobbiamo comunque
andare lì anche se dice di non entrare
che per i costi calice al
videoregistratore a che ti amo questa ed
il culo
[Musica]
esperimento 10 06
in pratica una cassetta in cui ha detto
che l'esperimento è andato male e che
quindi ha registrato questa cassetta per
far sapere a tutti che non bisogna più
fare questi esperimenti sui giocattoli e
se si fanno bisogna contenerli ed
eliminarli subito e all'improvviso si è
fermato perché hanno preso anche lui
quindi la storia è questa loro stavano
facendo stanno cercando di creare un
giocattolo interattivo con una coscienza
solo che poi questo giocattolo si è
rivoltato verso più dell'oro rivelato si
è ribellato verso di loro e gli
eliminati tutti questo giocatore roba
anche i luoghi che il noi siamo riusciti
eliminare adesso ma non so se lo abbiamo
eliminato per sempre andiamo vediamo
cosa è successo chi ci sarà adesso lumi
dire che ti avevamo il cubano non
abbiamo eliminato il pupazzo
sembra una casa una casa antica
non mi dire che c'è un altro giocattolo
malefico qua
un altro esperimento bambola
sentito la bambola che sarà l'inizio
[Musica]
non mi dire che dobbiamo affrontare
anche le op
qui si sente carriola
per una casa delle bambole
dovere
no queste sono dei cuscini
sarà qui se qualcuno
la bambola poppy per fortuna è rinchiusa
là dentro
adesso
dobbiamo per forza aprirla sta dormendo
secondo me dovremmo prima un ohio abrams
fox non era una buona idea forza
capitolo wow
sapevo finito
nei dati quindi abbiamo liberato po pd e
penso che sarà un altro capitolo in cui
dovremmo combattere o eliminare poppi la
bambola per cosa che abbiamo stupito
antigua di voi non avete idea di quante
volte
in cui scappavamo in quell'abito siamo
morti di cui 100 quale ci fa più paura
tra i scream e questo secondo me quello
che secondo me scrivetelo nei commenti
e ora mi lasciavo qua quattro cartellini
e su cui cliccare per vedere i nostri
altri video il caldo su quella che
preferite buona visione ciao